but when I saw that picture I was like I
was like I can see why he got ran over
[Music]
all right Nick you're gonna love this
one it's a very heartwarming story it's
quite good has a nice ending 12 year old
boy was riding his bike in Jerusalem he
was hit by a car pretty much got run
over and uh his head was decapitated
from his body
why would I like this they reattached it
is back alive yay
[Applause]
they did what
what holy [__]
do that so they completely you're right
I do like this
okay
God damn it dude
wait they know how to [__] do that no
so here's the thing it says head rolled
and then they just put it back on it
wasn't a straight decapitation it's a
specific kind of decapitation called
internal decapitation which sounds even
crazy okay so what happened is bone wise
oh like his ver his base of his skull
got detached from his verb right oh my
God but the blood vessels and skin were
all connected holy [__] so the so so
everything was like still brief nervous
so he got glow stick so he probably he
probably cracked his lipstick it cracks
on the inside that's what the doctor
said that's crazy
I understand what was happening classic
case of glow stick but then is he
paralyzed no he's not he's totally fine
he doesn't even have any like cognitive
uh like what if he's evil now what if
he's evil now that's the question that
is the question wait so he was
cross-eyed before what I was hoping
nobody would I was that honestly can I
say something that was the first thing I
saw well because you weren't looking for
some sort of neck if you said it went
back to original that means he was
cross-eyed before it had nothing to do
with cross nerves yeah
when you turn the picture over the first
thing I noticed was the eyes straight up
dude was that you I think it's a fighter
thing we just look in the honor Fighters
like
oh so his leg his ligaments everything
he didn't know who he was looking at
he's a cross-eyed Southpaw I see
so the ligaments in the muscle cut but
the skin and the vessels isn't that
crazy very crazy yeah so he's he's
basically like in a sec because I guess
when you do you know when you see those
crash videos like your limbs do like
they all just yeah shoes like fall off
and [__] so maybe that's what happened
his like everything was so loose I just
went like like 40 in disaster so they
basically the doctors at this hospital
just had to make a really fast judgment
call and they were able to save them and
literally this kid talking fine no
neurological deficit it's because it's
the land of Jesus kinda huh
why are you so mean that's what they
said no no I didn't hear him sound they
heard juicy how are you not hearing him
you're so mean for not hearing your
husband can I say something I love her
so much I [__] love you can I say
something this isn't a knock on the kid
at all I was saying you're so mean wait
when is when is cross-eyed ever a bad
thing it's not a bad thing stop bringing
it up I used to call it cockeyed okay
cockeyed but when you hear about a story
about a kid getting his head decapitated
yeah and then you say we saved him and
then you show me the picture and the
first thing I noticed is the cross side
that's all right you're just judgmental
it's not judgmental it's just noticeable
you know how much game this guy can spit
now he probably could he's gonna be like
Crush nothing could stop me he's he's
going to be CEO so you're saying right
that if this was your kid and you're in
the waiting room like God I hope he's
okay they go Nick he's gonna make it
he's fine and then bring him out and he
goes
hey Dad
you're gonna have a problem with that
yeah is that what you're saying I'm not
gonna have a problem I'm just saying
that it's noticeable your dogs look like
that now that's what I'm saying and
guess what and I look at my dogs and I
go
that's not funny dude okay those are my
are you serious you're doing that he's
laughing he's laughing this is JK news
you kind of put me on the spot Geo real
hard anytime he says
that was the line that you crossed it
why are you yelling at me so we didn't
we didn't establish it was cross-eyed
before
this old photo of himself
how'd you get a picture attached when
you say something Geo say something he's
spitting he's the one giving us the
report he's not making this up he just
said it looked like Tesh yeah how'd you
get a picture attention you're just
writing out random things now I'm just
sad he didn't actually get is he
cross-eyed I wanted him to be backwards
okay look is this cross-eyed wait that's
not the same kid same kid it is the same
kid you guys are [__] up oh the other
kid who just showed me that was this big
on screen yeah
save kid okay look are you serious bro
that's not cross-eyed that's evil eyes
that's what I said remember
things honestly if I had to fight that
guy I'd be like God damn what I'm gonna
lose
dude he for sure woke up Slytherin dude
look at that
just like looking at you know like
sometimes you get caught looking at two
things and that's fine he died and came
back to life he came back with like eye
shadow yeah it makes it like evil some
people dressed he just got the cabinet
man that's that's crazy that's a big
deal
JK shout out just take it away dude if
that happened to my kid he got [__]
ran over in my mind I'm like okay
[__] Tiger's gone right but it's like
if the [__] two doctors are able to
come out yo we can fix them I'm like oh
my God I'll [__] suck a dick right
now I have a reporter host question yeah
how did they know he was decapitated if
it was internal
he became a big highlighter color yeah
you know like if you you got a pack of
crackers and without opening the package
you just smash the [__] out of it you
can just tell the broken it's like that
and you don't want to buy it you're like
not me you know those crackers are
smushed you know the success rate here
you need a Jewish doctor that's what you
mean Oh I thought you wanted to know
it's 55 really oh that's a high success
rate it is 55 55 of people that this
happens to don't survive that moment of
impact is 55 failure or success rate
that's not it doesn't matter it's right
in the middle dude no that's better than
Blackjack on
55 is amazing
where's the five percent man so that
makes a difference that's that's not the
surgery that's like right when it
happens you either die or you're just
this like that's half and half dude but
it's better odds it's better odds than
Blackjack that's all I'm saying in a
casino if 55 was in my favor I'd be a
rich dude you'd be like I take those
odds what are you saying that you would
what what did you just say
it's a good it's a good odd question of
the year so they had to fuse got it they
took his like skull and they fused the
base of it back to his spinal column
using screws rods plates and bone graft
bone that's amazing man modern medicine
is crazy no you need Jewish doctors
Jewish doctors there's no other there's
no other photo of him other than that
one like in existence in Jerusalem
there's not a [__] influencer you
need a combination of Science and
spirituality it sucks when you get a
before and after pick you got prayer and
you got doctorism
that's amazing though because man if
that happened to taika oh my God I don't
know what I would do I lose my [__] I
don't mind if it comes back cross side
if he's alive yeah that's true but he
got evil eyes
is evil she's pointing at Joe
perspectives often off I was like I have
the resume of loving cross-eyed things
it is pretty funny to imagine that he's
just evil now yeah bro but that happens
though when you get hit by a car with
brain trauma some people like their
personality they have a different like
accent I think it's just that anesthesia
didn't wear off yes yeah he's still a
little loser still kind of like highest
[__] alone I gotta take a picture I
still like that both of these guys saw
across on they're like it's a fighter
thing he said it yeah
yeah like as a fire you can spot
cross-eyed people way easier that we all
can't see it what if he came back to
life but that was a perfect moment for a
demon to go inside of him okay that's an
824 result that's a thing dude
he came back to life as a demon and he
goes it's my turn now it looks like what
he's saying okay that's why I said it at
the beginning so sometimes there's a
cost right there's a cost to to some of
this stuff he's like because it's it is
Jerusalem so it's like the second coming
of Christ now it's the first coming of
Satan douche watch this I got it so he
was already evil okay the person that
wanted to run him over was trying to
Jesus
it was a Chinese tourist so it was Jesus
he time traveled to present day Chinese
tourists why would Jesus
always he he's human form yeah but this
time as a Chinese tourist okay he rented
a car right and he's out to get future
Satan and then and these doctors and
then these stupid back together you
tried to do a Highlander yeah yeah
you didn't get me Jesus
hopefully there's enough fighters in
Jerusalem that can spot this kid because
regular people can't see that honestly
we should keep an eye on this kid I
almost died he has eyes on you
it's the same picture no the other kid
that he pulled
he pulled off like I was like I I can
see why he got ran over
so [__] because he wasn't seeing the
road right because the intersections
look different to him I could see what
he got run over because he sees double
vision
how could you say that this was a
Chinese tourist Jesus